we are very very honored today to
welcome distinguished alumnus sp he got
this piece and use computer science his
undergraduate degrees are in math and in
Latin from Xavier University and as he
told me earlier this morning he was
amazed that Ellenville was willing to
take a bet on the leverage was it freely
the peerless was willing to take a bet
on the last dollar but it's clear that
the best paid often Chuck co-founded
Adobe in 1982 adobe has been a leader
and continues to be a leader in the
field of software for more than 35 years
now Chuck and his co-founder John were
not stepped off
say the day leaders of the dhobi 10,000
but they continue to share the turbine
ship with the boy I was telling Chuck
earlier that we have these days such an
entrepreneurial culture among
undergraduate 6 p.m. news that this was
going to be an instance for students to
hear how Chuck did this and Chuck said
well extended been possible no one's
going to be able to do this and I
thought because no one's you know
because times have changed and the
situation that allowed them to start
Adobe and allowed them to be of success
by the end of their very first year is
not the kind of thing they find today
however the story of the passion and the
persistence and the vision that Chuck
brought to the founding of Adobe is
certainly something when we were talking
earlier about how companies and how
university departments go from a startup
phase to a sustainable phase Chuck was
explaining that one of the reasons that
adobe has been so successful is that
they allow people to be who they are and
they think of three kinds of people
company they think of the arrow shooters
who can hit a particular target the
scouts who see how to get there and the
road builders who make sure that
everybody does get to that particular
place but what Chuck explains was by the
time they started Adobe what was
remaining to do was to build that road
and that's because Chuck and John did an
extraordinary job at being both scout
and arrow shooter and finding a target
that nobody else had even dreamed
existed out there and then inspiring
other people to move towards that target
Adobe was not all that long ago judged
to be one of the most amazed admired
American companies by Fortune magazine
ranked number one in the category of
computer software of most admired
American companies and Chuck said that
they did not have a complicated
philosophy of what it meant to be image
there wasn't a 400-page handbook there
was one page of values so join me in
welcoming and first of all could you
hear me in the back
great second of all thank you so much
for their kind introduction now my job
is to live up to it which is always a
challenge so I did not come here today
to sort of speak to you about a
commercial for Adobe or give you
necessarily a biography of myself but
the one advantage of getting old is that
if you have any memory left at all you
sort of remember how you got to where
you are and I always think that that's
sometimes helpful for young people like
yourselves to at least have an idea of
how one story worked its way from its
concepts through its fruition and I do
remember sitting in a place like this
not nearly as nice as this building by
the way but in a place like this at CMU
in 1968 and sitting there wondering
would I ever be able to get my PhD from
an institution of this quality and in
this level and fortunately I fooled them
and I got out so that was good I do want
to talk about my experience in founding
a Silicon Valley startup and share with
you not only some of the lessons that
I've learned but a little bit about some
of the mistakes that can occur along the
way and I'm going to use the example of
Adobe because it's the thing I know the
best as a way to talk to you about what
it means to start a business but the
fact that I'm using Adobe at the example
don't focus too much on that focus on
the sort of lessons that we learned
along the way and I'll give you some
anecdotal evidence
well of why building a set of principles
for the company or the computer science
department or whatever it is that you
build in your life is so critical to its
long-term success so I'm going to talk
about the steps it took to get to start
up how a kid who was the first in his
family to go to college could manage to
get all the way through a degree in
classics and somehow start a computer
company secondly the fact that it has
turned out to be successful when the
batting average is less than 5% and some
of it is timing a lot of it is luck and
or of course is some also some hard work
as well and in particular it's always
interesting and as you think about
companies and you hear about them it's
always informative to figure out how
they get through the bad times very easy
to talk about the good times everybody
loves to talk about that but how you
experience the tough times and all of
some things to say about that and I'll
finish with a few comments on some of
the things that keep me up at night
relative to technology and where we are
in this country well I grew up not too
far away about 150 miles northeast of
here in Cleveland Ohio I went to a
private Jesuit High School I say private
it really was parochial supported by the
Jesuits and then I went on to a Jesuit
University Xavier and as I've already
said and you've heard my undergraduate
degree was in classics I was intrigued
by the liberal arts I always thought
that it was important to have a broad
education even though I came from a
family in which no one else had the
opportunity to go to college and but I
took a lot of mathematics because I
figured eventually I'd have to figure
out something to do and based on
finishing my master's degree in
mathematics there I got a job teaching
at John Carroll University which is also
in Cleveland and while I was teaching I
was working on my doctorate at Case
Western Reserve after about two or three
years of teaching we had a
cailli meeting and we decided one of our
graduate students wasn't going to make
and so somebody had to tell him this we
drew straws and of course I got the
short straw and so I brought him into my
office I did my very best not to defeat
his feeling of self-worth but I did tell
him he was going to have to leave and
find something else to do about a year
later he called me and he wanted to come
back and visit me in my office hmm well
I said yes but I said boy this could be
awkward depending on how the last year
has gone for him but he came by big grin
when he walked into my office said you
know the best thing you ever did for me
is kick me out of here said I got this
job selling computers for General
Electric and I've made so much money in
the last year that I just had to come
back and thank you and I've been trying
to think of how I could show my
gratitude and it occurred to be if
perhaps you would like to learn how to
program a computer yeah I'd love to
he said fine I'll come back in the
evenings during the summer and teach you
how to program so he did and I wrote
some programs in Fortran on a small
computer the only program that I
remember actually finishing was a
program to print out those addressable
envelopes for the announcement of my
daughter's birth our second child not a
strong background in computer science I
would say at that point but unbeknownst
to me there was this program going on
with the US government called ARPA and
ARPA was really a fall out of the
Sputnik event back in 1957 and the
decision was that we had to start
getting serious about funding more basic
research in the area of space
exploration and defenses against people
who might get to space before us during
the transition from the Eisenhower
administration to Kennedy
I took Kennedy aside and said I've been
told by some advisers I really respect
in the Department of Defense that we
cannot depend in the long run on analog
communication
to run a worldwide military I've been
told that we have to convert to digital
communications and I think it's
important that you take that advice
seriously this is Ike speaking to JFK
now my assumption is that neither one of
those politicians knew what that
sentence meant which was fun but Kennedy
took it seriously and he decided hmm the
guy who's got the biggest budget in my
cabinet and the fellow who is sort of
most technical from his background at
Ford Motor his name McNamara I'll give
him the job so he told McNamara he
wanted him to figure out what to do
McNamara in turn knew a lot of people at
MIT and in particular was introduced to
a man by the name of JCR Licklider who
was actually not an electrical engineer
or dealing directly himself with any
research and computers his PhD was in
psycho acoustics but he was a remarkable
guy and so what McNamara said is I'm
going to give you a few tens of millions
of dollars and I want you to figure out
not just how to do some research so if
Congress ever asks a question we can
defend ourselves but more importantly I
want you to train a whole new cadre of
people who can become experienced in
electronics electrical engineering and a
term computer science didn't exist at
that time but in basically computer
science well look lighter decided he
would not do an NSF like program where
he give a lot of people a very little
amount of money instead he was going to
give 30 to 40 times a typical NSF grant
to a few Centers of Excellence and he
would select those centers of excellence
by the quality of the people who had
leadership positions in those
organizations a few of them were
industrial research labs like Rand bolt
Beranek and Newman in Boston mitre
corporation Stanford Research Institute
out in Menlo Park but most of them were
universities and he started out with
about a dozen plus or minus a little
of Stanford Cal UCLA Caltech University
of Utah University of Michigan the
University of Illinois Carnegie Mellon
Kearney Tech of course in those days and
Harvard MIT and there may have been one
or two others and he went to each of
them he selected the principal
scientists who were gonna run in effect
those organizations and here at Carnegie
Tech he picked of course the great
triumvirate of perlis Simon and Newell
and they were the ARPA contractors he
said I'm not going to micromanage you
I'll come by a few times a year sort of
check in see how things are growing you
won't have to write an awful lot of
reports but you'll have to do whatever
is necessary to make sure that Congress
if they check our content that we're
doing this correctly but he said most
importantly I want you to take a
significant portion of the funds and
educate graduate students obviously this
was in the university's not the private
labs and he said secondly I also want
you to be responsible for doing has
brought a horizontal communication
within this community of institutions as
is possible and in fact I'm going to
demand that you do that on a regular
basis and that you don't think of the
research you do as something you own you
think of it as something that's being
contributed to this pool of research and
based on that almost all of the senior
management in Silicon Valley were
educated as ARPA brats I was on our per
breath everyone who was a graduate
student in CMU if they didn't have an
independent scholarship and in our for
scholarship and that's really how
Silicon Valley was developed was an
incredible program was done in a very
unique way and I often wonder what the
world of alternative energy would be
like had we done a similar program in
the researcher is around that but that's
a whole other conversation
at any rate so I showed up at the door
Alan Perlis said fine you've got two
kids you'll get 350 a month instead of
300 and in 1968 you could survive on
that and so my wife who had noticed that
I was becoming more interested in
computers than I was in my mathematics
which I was about to start my thesis in
and I said you know you're really sure
we you want to do this and he says she
said Chuck I want you to follow your
dream because that will make you
successful best advice you could ever
possibly get and I did follow my dream
four years later I got out by then we
had three kids not exactly plan but
that's the way it worked out in 1972 I
had to get a job of course my thesis
advisor and I was very fortunate bill
Wolfe was my thesis advisor many or most
of you probably know either know him or
of him and I picked I shouldn't say I
picked he picked me and I was grateful
he did because he was brand-new it was
the first year on the faculty and I knew
that any entering professor how to get
some students graduated and I figured if
I could catch his coattails I could get
out of here too but an irate when I
finished I decided I did not want to go
on in teaching I wanted to go work in an
industrial research lab and I got a job
offer to come to Xerox PARC and Xerox
PARC was a magical place
now the reason Xerox PARC existed was
that Peter McCullough the chairman of
the board and David Kearns the president
of Xerox had an incredibly successful
company but it only had one product the
copier and they knew instinctively as
anyone knows in business you can't be a
single product company and survive
forever
you've got to diversify they thought at
first that they would put their
resources into research and house it
where the center of their development
was in Rochester New York but they
pretty quickly understood that the
antibodies from the copier business
would kill off in a new research almost
immediately so they hired a fella George
pake
physicist out of Washington University
in st. Louis and he ended up deciding to
take a piece of property for lease in
Silicon Valley at the Stanford
industrial park very good idea that
Stanford had developed that that part in
order to keep their graduates and some
of their faculty in close proximity to
the University and in turn he hired two
people jerry alkyne from bolt Beranek
and Newman and Bob Taylor who was
Licklider successor at ARPA and the
reason those two hires were so critical
is they knew where all the ARPA brats
were and they knew who were the most
likely to be helpful and successful in
getting a research program going and
they hired us when I arrived in the fall
of 72 and in the office next to me was a
guy named Bob Metcalfe who invented the
ethernet and built 3com a whole variety
of people at Xerox PARC went on to do
things that were quite incredible both
within the research lab but elsewhere
unfortunately afterwards and I say
unfortunately because we all join Xerox
hoping to bring Xerox into the future
in fact in 1976 in my office I had a
personal computer called the alto had
some interesting software on it a text
editing program called Bravo which if
you looked at it you would think it was
Microsoft Word and it was because the
fellow who did it left and went to Xerox
and built office for Microsoft Chuck's
of Charles Simoni it was on a network
the Ethernet it was hooked up to a
60-page a minute black-and-white printer
a 10-page minute color printer was
hooked up to file servers where we could
store information and share it and as a
subcontractor to ARPA we were on the
ARPANET
so we were sending electronic mail
throughout the ARPA community as well as
within Xerox Corporation were eventually
there were over a thousand of these
computers 1976 many of you are too young
to know this the IBM PC did not get in
until 1981 five years later in 1977 I
and two of my companions were given the
job of putting on a demonstration to
Xerox senior management of what the
office of the future could look like it
was to be done at a meeting that Xerox
held on a biannual basis of their top
250 managers worldwide this time it was
in Boca Raton Florida
so we ended up leasing space on a couple
of DC tens personal computers were a
little bigger in those days and flew all
the equipment and printers and
everything down to Florida set
everything up in the morning we put on a
stage production which is actually
prototyped for us by on a soundstage in
Hollywood of what the office of the
future could look like and then in the
afternoon we ran a trade show so that
all of the Xerox executives and because
it was both business and social also
their wives girlfriends and by the way I
didn't say the Xerox executives and
their husbands because I think all 250
of those executives were men this was
the body language of a Xerox executive
looking at what they saw in this walk-in
exhibition it scared to death is what
this means hope it goes away soon hope I
never have to deal with it
they were copier guys that's what they
understood they didn't understand any of
this computer so while their wives and
girlfriends had all worked in offices so
they sat down they played with the mouse
they clicked on a button out came a
printed page it looked the same as what
was on the display they said wow this is
really cool they were ultimately the
customers or at least the clients of
what this office of the future could
provide well the reaction of Xerox
executives was not lost on us who were
in research and it was actually fairly
depressing because it was clear was
going to be a real uphill battle to get
Xerox to bring anything out but when I
got back to Palo Alto I was given the
opportunity to start
a new laboratory within the research
center focused on graphics and printing
my first job was to go out and hire a
sort of principal or chief scientist for
that laboratory and I had known by
reputation a fella by the name of John
Warnock who had gotten his PhD at the
University of Utah
also when ARPA brat and at the time was
working in Mountain View California for
NASA Ames under contract from a Salt
Lake company called Evans & Sutherland I
call him up said let's have lunch we had
lunch he had a beard I had a beard still
married to the same woman you're married
originally so was i he had three kids
two boys and a girl I had three kids two
boys and a girl and we both refereed
soccer which closed the deal so I hired
him and best hiring decision I made in
my entire life and John came to work and
we did a variety of different things and
then eventually we were approached by
the quote product group which never
really succeeded that was going to try
and get the summit semblance of the
office of the future out into the
marketplace and at the last minute they
discovered that they couldn't print now
for Xerox not to be able to print it
would have been a real problem because
they had a whole history of putting
marks on paper so they called us in and
said we need some help we put together a
sort of crash project to design a
language that would allow you to take
any application running on any computer
specify the description of what the
printed page should look like and send
it to any printer of any resolution of
any characteristics could be black and
white could be color and it would print
it we called it inter press the Xerox
management loved it they said we're
going to standardize on this and for our
young laboratory had only been open a
couple of years this was a big deal so I
immediately got an airplane I flew back
to Stamford Connecticut and I said this
is wonderful when can we start marketing
inter press to the world and I said whoa
wait a minute
that's Xerox it takes seven years to
bring out a product really that's seven
years yep
I said well so we can't talk about this
nope
because if you do the Japanese and other
people will beat us to the market and
take it away and I said well seven years
is two to three generations in in the
industry that we're in are going to be
in it'll be such old news by the time
you bring out a product it'll be
worthless sorry
seven years of Xerox well that pushed me
and Jon over the edge and through his
thesis advisor at the University of Utah
Dave Evans we were introduced to a man
by the name of Bill Hamburg who was the
founder of Hamburg and Quist
one of the very first venture firms out
in the San Francisco Bay Area and we
John and I said that we had an idea that
we wanted to put together some computers
some laser printers some plate making
equipment and a whole bunch of software
so we could build a complete solution
for in-house publishing and sell it into
the fortune 500 turns out unbeknownst to
us bill hated in financial printers and
he saw this as a way to put them out of
business
so he said okay I like the idea I'll
support it and you have to quit your
jobs
what said really yeah you got to quit
your jobs and I will give you two and a
half million dollars over two years to
get started in building your idea and
turning it into a product he said oh by
the way have either of you ever run a
business and we said oh no he said well
fine I'll hire a guy to help you write
the business plan so I can raise the
money but don't worry about that
so we did hired a guy wrote the business
plan proved it we got our two and a half
well commitment to two and a half
million it was actually in two payment
one on the quarter million each year we
opened our doors started hiring and very
early on Gordon Bell called and when to
come by and see what we were doing
Gordon had been my hardware professor
here at Carnegie Mellon but at that
point in his career he was running
research and development for digital
equipment
so he comes by he looks at what we're
doing he said wow this is very
fascinating he said but I don't I don't
need computers I'm deck and I got this
deal with Rico for laser printers so I
don't need any laser printers my problem
is I've got two or three development
teams trying to figure out how to
interface the applications running on
these computers to these printers and
they're getting nowhere why don't you
just sell me that software that you've
got and we said we have this business
plan gonna race two and a half million
dollars we can't do that and he said
well if you change your mind give me a
call about six weeks later friend of
ours who had left Xerox and went to work
for Apple Computer and had the job of
running the Macintosh development
program brought Steve Jobs by Steve
looked at where we're doing is very
impressed by it he said I don't need
computers I got this thing the Macintosh
it'll be out another year and I've got a
deal with Kannon for a laser printer so
I don't need a laser printer why don't
you sell me your company and come work
for Apple and provide me that software
and we said no Steve we're starting our
own business we're not gonna sell the
company he said okay well I can sort of
understand that he said all right then
how about we'll do a deal and you'll
sell me the software and we said Steve
we have this business he said well I
think you guys are nuts
when you change your mind call me so we
went and talked to the man who bill
hamberg had put in charge of our board
our the chairman of our board we would
around forever and he looked at us and
he said you guys are nuts
I said forget the business plan throw
out the damn business plan he said it
was only there to raise money now you
know what your customers want give it to
him so I go back and I call up Steve and
I say Steve we've changed our mind he
says great what do you want for the
company I said Steve the company's not
for sale
okay let's do a deal so we did a deal
with Apple right at the end of our first
year in business for which they gave us
a prepayment on future royalties
about one and a half million dollars and
they bought 19.9% of the company when
you guys take your business courses
you'll know why it was 19.9% it so you
don't have to consolidate earnings and
he paid five times what the original
investors pay so at the end of our first
year we had returned a multiple of five
to our investors and we were returning
we were cashflow positive and had a
profit this never happens okay
doesn't happen but it did happen to us
and obviously we've been eternally
grateful for that but we had this an
incredible opportunity now that begin
building something that could really
make our company move forward quickly
and what we did is we signed a contract
to develop the original laserwriter for
Apple and the later writer was the first
PostScript printer to come to market it
was introduced in January of 1985 two
very positive technical acclaim and the
product began selling very well for
Apple and and all of a sudden this all
started to go like this well the problem
was that Apple at that time had decided
that their marketing campaign was to
sell the Macintosh office problem was
they weren't IBM there was no way on
either price or feet on the street that
they could compete with IBM and they
were losing market share very rapidly to
the PC fortunately there was a marketing
guy at Apple who did not believe in the
Macintosh office but he knew about a
company up in Seattle called Aldus that
had a program called PageMaker which did
page layout on a macintosh he knew about
PostScript and the laser printer and
together the three companies invented a
brand new marketing campaign for
ourselves an apple called desktop
publishing and by the summer of late
summer early fall of 1985 the sales of
both the Macintosh and the laser writers
started to take off again
in our first year of having actual
revenue we had four million dollars in
revenue then we went to 16 million to 39
million to 83 million to 129 million we
were on a rocket ship we have three
stock splits during that period because
we run public in the summer in August of
1986 our public offering was four five
and a half million dollars
nobody gasped none of you guys are
business guys that's the trouble you're
all technical guys by the way when we
started the company I did read one
business book and I only remember one
chapter in the book and the chapter was
market gap analysis and what it said was
if you're gonna start a product or a
business look for a place in the
marketplace where there's a need but
nobody has currently got a solution to
fill that need and do that and then
you'll have a hundred percent market
share and shame on you if he can't keep
most of it well John I thought that was
a good idea so that in fact has been the
philosophy behind our business but I
also didn't realize that five and a half
million dollars it was really small and
but we didn't need cash because we were
profitable in cash positive our
shareholders were quite happy because
they were already able to begin to sell
stock so this rocket ship okay anything
that goes up in my experience eventually
comes down at least as long as you have
gravity so by 1989 we were doing
spectacular well and then all of a
sudden our biggest customer Apple and
our biggest competitor Microsoft decided
to get together and see if they could
put us out of business we had developed
some type technology so that you could
not only get high quality typography on
the printer but also on the screen Apple
decided they were going to do their own
thing something called TrueType
Microsoft decided that this was an
opportunity for a wedge because they had
bought one of the 70 postscript clone
man developers out of the marketplace
and they said okay Apple will give you
the clone so you don't have to pay Adobe
any more royalties and will take your
typefaces and put them up on Windows
which will give you instant a hundred
percent market share in that business
and forget about Adobe well that was
very sobering and when something like
that happens you sort of have to make a
gut check and go back to the core
principles that you had in mind when you
started your business the first
principle that John and I agreed on the
media when we started Adobe is that we
wanted to build a company that we
personally would like to work for we
figured if we'd like to work for it all
the other nerds that we knew would like
to work for it - so that was principle
number one second principle was that we
was clear that we were a business that
was built exclusively with intellectual
capital you know we had no factories we
really didn't make anything the fact
that you had a distribute software on a
disk was sort of an accident in those
days and we really had nothing other
than what was in the heads of our
employees and ourselves that was real
capital or real ownership by the company
of anything we also had a principle of
that we would hire the very best people
that we could find independent of
whether they're male or female whatever
their ethnic background was whatever
their cultural preferences were didn't
matter just so they were the best people
that we could find for the jobs that we
were trying to hire for and in fact I've
always told our managers hire people who
are smarter than you first of all it's a
larger population from which to choose
and glad you got that one and and
secondly if you hire people who are
smarter than you they'll take your job
away and you'll have to get promoted so
it's the best way to develop your career
the other principle we had is that we
wanted to build a company of inventors
our job was to innovate and to build
products that fulfill that market gap
analysis that I mentioned a few moments
ago so if you look like a product or a
technology like PostScript there was
nothing like that in the market in those
days you either had a dot matrix printer
or a simulated typewriter that was run
like a printer nothing that could take
raster and produced high-quality
topography line art and photographs
Photoshop when we introduced Photoshop
there were no digital cameras the
scanner was about the size of a
refrigerator and cost forty to fifty
thousand dollars there were no inkjet
printers that could produce high quality
prints in your home or in your office
yet instinctively we knew that of
printing went digital
then photography and eventually video
would have to and so we went in there
early got a hundred percent market share
tried to sell the idea to Kodak Kodak
said no we like yellow boxes yellow
boxes are our future went to Japan to
Fuji they said very interesting they
took on the technology and they built
some of the first digital cameras
acrobat when acrobat came out there was
no internet which came out about three
or four years early people sort of
didn't have this concept of the
electronic document but it has ended up
in resulting in trillions of pages out
in the World Wide Web and pretty much on
every person's computer so though that
thing of thriving on innovation was
critical the other thing we
instinctively knew and probably mostly
learned is that to be a successful
company we had to manage forkin
- ensues our customers our employees our
shareholders and the communities in
which we operate it and if you think
about that for a moment each of those
constituencies is somewhat mildly in
some cases more violently in opposition
to one another what's good for one is
not good for the other all right
employees want to get paid a lot of
money shareholders want you to turn in
it an unusually large profit those are
not necessarily linked up however how
you manage those constituencies and how
you balance them so that each one of
them thinks they're getting a fair deal
is critical to your long-term success as
a business and finally people would
often ask us well you know we're part of
Adobe now sort of how should we behave
do you have a manual that tells us the
rules of how you should be an Adobe
employee and we'd say no I have no
intention to writing such a manual we
have one very simple principle and that
is if you are a member of the Adobe
family you treat your employee you treat
your boss you treat your customer you
treat your shareholder you treat the
people in the community in which you're
running your business the way you'd like
to be treated if you do that those
people will be your allies they will
like you and like doing business with
you and that was the whole Adobe
principle now we didn't do this in a
vacuum we were trying our best to take
the best parts of the HP tradition and
sort of reef codify them for our age and
for our business but how you treat
people is so critical to the success of
whether it's a business a university a
nonprofit doesn't matter what it is so
the real question is with this threat
now from Microsoft and Apple is this
really good business or is it Chuck just
up there or sort of talk
motherhood and apple pie you know and
doesn't really mean anything well it so
happens that the announcement of this
unholy partnership between Apple and
Microsoft occurred at a major conference
in the publishing industry it was called
the siebold conference put on by
jonathan see bowl was held a couple
times a year once on the west coast once
on the east coast this one happened to
be in san francisco and of course the
organizers of the conference love
controversy like this so they
immediately added a new session on the
last day of the conference in which
there would be a panel discussion of
would you prefer to go with the
direction that Apple and Microsoft are
promising or would you prefer to stick
with the dope wasn't the exact title but
that was the idea
close enough so the conference had about
1500 attendees at the sessions there was
also a trade show that went on in
parallel with it and so the room was
full I stood in the back of the room
saying I wonder what I'll be doing for
my next career and the moderator said
well the first thing I want to do is
take a straw poll how many of you think
it would be better if Apple and
Microsoft got together and basically
just took away Adobe's business and we
went with them now I can't tell you that
there were no hands raised in the room
there were a few but I think most of
them were either Apple or Microsoft
employees and and in fact the whole tone
of that discussion for an hour and a
half was of course not
Adobe is the leader in terms of opening
up new technology their products work
we're happy with them by this point we
were also shipping illustrator and they
said we want to stick with Adobe well we
had a second thing ready and that is we
had the technology for putting that
typeface solution on both Macintoshes
and PCs we introduced it to the market
about 60 days after this conference
it immediately began selling hundreds of
thousands of units a month and it took
three years for Microsoft to finally get
TrueType on the PC so it became a
non-issue after precisely three months I
meant to say three years three years to
get that out and it turns out that Apple
never shipped a printer with the clone
because it never worked I believe that
the reason those people voted that way
was because of the way we treated them
as a company I think that was absolutely
critical there was one other time this
happened and I'll be very quick about
this one in 1998 John and I decided it
was time to get ready to retire we went
outside the company to try and hire new
management it failed utterly we fired
all four of the potential new CEOs on
the same day that was followed by an
announcement out of Japan that the
market had cratered over therefore
computer software all of a sudden our
expenses were well ahead of our earnings
we had to do a layoff and we had to
pre-announce a bad quarter that's not a
good combination of things to have to
deal with as a result our one competitor
in one market area that actually taken
the market away from Aldus and pager
maker was a company called quark got a
product called Express now quark was an
interesting company it was not a public
company but they had generated a lot of
cash and the guy who ran it was sort of
an ornery fellow and his customers did
not like him but they bought his product
because the technology was very good but
he didn't treat them very fairly they
never got upgrades they had to pay a
whole new license for the thing and it
wasn't we're just not dealt with as a
nice company fortunately this all
happened once again in the fall at the
time of the Sebold conference once again
there was a panel quark takeover Adobe
Adobe sale up same results except this
time I think there wasn't a single hand
raised in new
because of the behavior of the CEO of
Court and we were given an opportunity
at that conference to show off InDesign
which was our answer to court and it is
the first and so far the only time we've
ever gone into a market that someone had
majority share today we have majority
share and quark is perilously close to
being out of business once again not
motherhood and apple pie just very good
business I may conclude with a couple of
things of sort of keeping you up at
night and I'll cut this back a bit so if
we have time for questions I already
talked about ARPA and how I would really
love to have seen ARPA do something
sorry something ARPA like to have been
done by the government in the area of
energy independence so far it hasn't
happened not sure it ever will but if
they could do it in the way that
Licklider organized ARPA in those early
days but in particular the information
projects office within ARPA it would be
an incredible benefit to this country
couple of Statistics some of these are
getting a little long in the tooth but
they're still relatively current China
and Qarth North South Korea have both
been increasing their investment in
basic research at the rate of ten
percent a year and they've been doing
that for more than a decade now I'll get
to the US in a moment it's pretty clear
that unless we do something like that
we're going to begin to lose scientists
in all fields not just in computing
there was a recent survey that was done
by Booz Allen back in in the middle of
the 2000s and by the end of 2007 China
India had gone from 19% of the personnel
in R&D to 31 percent of the world's
percentage that's pretty huge growth
in global R&D right these things look
pretty good the United States leads and
we have 34 percent of the total money
being spent in R&D worldwide and if you
throw Japan into the mix that's more
than 50% of the money spent but that may
not be the most meaningful statistic I
think a more meaningful one is how much
of the R&D money do we spend as a
percentage of our GDP and how does that
compare to other countries when you
throw that in things change and now we
ranked seventh in R&D and we're behind
Sweden Finland Japan Switzerland Iceland
and South Korea that's a good well let's
talk about basic research because the D
is sort of muddy because you're really
building products you may or may not be
doing something that's incredibly
innovative well in basic research global
spending we ranked 11th as a country if
you take the defense and that's as a
percentage of GDP so we ranked 11th if
you take out defense research we ranked
22nd probably always say we're number
one as I look at data now we're not
number one in very many things maybe in
dad and that's not good and the popular
political theory is well business will
pick up the gap business isn't picking
up the gap business is getting rid of
R&D not sorry
not deep Oh basic research you know Bell
Labs I assume there's still something
that has roughly that name but it's not
the Bell Labs that I knew as a young
person growing up IBM research has
gotten much smaller we just don't see
much are now of course like anyone in
Silicon Valley my real nightmare the
thing that keeps me up is two guys in a
garage that I've never heard of because
they could do something that could come
completely disrupt our business and you
see that happening on a regular basis I
mean who knew that those two graduate
students at Stanford would come up with
the idea of Google or that guy at
Harvard who was sort of according to the
movie a little out of the social
mainstream would come up with Facebook I
mean that's amazing stuff and very
disruptive to other businesses I'll
conclude by just a couple of comments on
what I value from my experience
obviously I've had the great good
fortune to not only be a co-founder of a
successful company and you do if you
won't stock on a company like that you
find yourself having more money than you
had expected but that's not what an
engineer dreams about an engineer a
scientist don't care which dreams about
coming up with something that millions
of people will find valuable and use
that's what drives us that's really what
you want to do that puts the stamp of
the importance on what you've achieved
and that's something that John and I and
all the early people of the Adobe have
had the experience of and it is by far
the most gratifying thing and it
manifests itself in lots of different
ways you read statistics you see other
companies who are trying to get rid of
it you know Steve gets up there and
complains about Flash but I know the
reason has nothing to do with technology
it has to do with his business approach
but the other thing that happens when
you have that impact and this has
happened to me many times over the last
20 plus years if you encounter people
who don't know who you are they find out
who you are they stick out their hand
and say thank you you made a difference
in my life it may have been starting a
business it may have been someone who
wanted to be a graphic artist but didn't
have the motor skills to be successful
but now that the computer had the motor
skills they could become successful
there are 10 times as many graphic
designers today as they were when
PostScript was first introduced to the
market and finally I think I may have
already mentioned this I'm not sure
sorry if I've forget what I said but my
father and grandfather were letterpress
photo engravers those are the people who
made the copper plates that were used to
do for color printing started around the
turn of the century and went through
most of the 20th century until
PostScript which completely replaced
that business in roughly a 10-year
period and when everything in printing
now
is fully electronic well my dad
fortunately lived to be almost 99 years
old and so after Adobe was founded he
was actually living with us and I
brought home one day some color
half-tones to show him and I knew they
weren't very good but I just wanted to
show them that we were starting to work
in that area
I showed it to him and my father always
had his engraving a loop with him took
the loop out look and looked up at me no
smile on his face he said Charles you
only called me Charles when there was a
problem Charles that doesn't look very
good I said I know dad I know but we're
making progress rapidly I assure you we
will eventually have something that you
will say is good okay I hope so
about year well not it wasn't even that
long maybe nine months later I knew we
had made the breakthroughs and that our
half-tones and I were in fact better
than most of the mechanical half-tones
that were produced so I brought a sample
home and I said hey dad take a look at
this it's about his loop look nope
looked at third shine looked again big
grin on his face he said Charlie you've
finally done it
and to me that was the most important
thing that came out of my experience and
starting Adobe thanks a lot there's a
lighted picture
come on I was sitting out there not too
long they Xerox was concerned about that
after they saw what we were doing but we
had checked very carefully with
intellectual property attorneys we
didn't take anything that we had done at
Xerox with us except the idea that was
in our head and that fortunately you
can't copyright or trademark someone
else's hit yes but no and that it was
very harmonious and our biggest
PostScript customer today is Xerox and
the market capitalization of Adobe is
bigger than Xeroxes interesting world we
live in
other questions people shy yeah in the
beginning you couldn't perform and
doubly today that was a little stronger
than I might have put it I think it's
the way in which we started Adobe first
of all today you've got to really work
hard to make sure the venture
capitalists don't give you too much
money
ironically even though that's now
changed a bit since 9 2008 but it's
still there and what I mean by that is
they want to own a significant piece of
what you're doing and the problem with
that is that then they want to sort of
take control of how you do it
that was something that bill hamberg and
hammering and Chris was great about and
he was on our board after we as a
startup company and he was very good
about the fact that they would not was
sort of Lickliter like he would not
micromanage us he wanted to know where
we were headed and he wanted us to come
to that board when we needed help or
advice about what
to do but he really gave us our hat that
sometimes is very hard to do today the
best venture capitalists still do it
that way but some don't the second thing
is that we were coming into a market in
which there weren't a lot of entrench
positions you know
yeah Microsoft was there but they
weren't selling Windows yet and so they
weren't nearly as big a force in fact
Bill Gates was at the introduction of
the larger writer and sat next to him
because they wanted to bring out their
office product on the Mac so that they
could take advantage of the Macs market
very different than the world is today
so we didn't have that kind of
entrenched position and we were able to
find pretty simply a market gap into
which we could move and the gap was huge
that's the other important ingredient
today that's again a lot harder to do
and the third thing that's harder to do
today is to go public you see that many
of the startup companies end up not
being able or deciding not to go public
and they get bought out by someone else
not all of them but we were able to go
public as I said on a offering of five
and a half million dollars and today
you'd have to be a multi billion dollar
valuation before any investment bank
would look at you in those days our
market camp after we were in public was
55 million nobody touched that today so
there are those kind of differences I'll
tell you the one other thing that might
be different and it's another thing that
keeps me up at night I saw recently
about two weeks ago a chart of the
number of students completing degrees
and all levels in computer science it's
now significantly lower than the number
was in 1982 this is in the u.s. that's
scary
scary for our industry and you know
fortunately there are a lot of great
students coming out of India and China
but it's hard to get them sometimes to
either come to or stay in the United
States because their world is getting
better in their own domestic markets and
that's a problem we are falling way
behind in terms of the manpower
necessary to maintain our position in
the world and that's scary I'm sorry
well then Department now school computer
science and Adobe has done ordered that
larger than it were originally can you
speak to the challenges of retaining the
culture and principles that well as we
started our company we hired people that
we already knew and we hired people who
were finishers nolan bushnell has a
great quote he said everyone who's ever
taken a showers had a great idea but we
know that if you want to be successful
you got to finish that idea and get it
to market
so in through that network the network
continued to bill and we hired people
that we knew clearly that's not possible
at our current side we have about a
9,000 employees about 1500 of them are
in India it's very different world what
we do though what the company does and
the management that we recruited to
replace us does is continually reinforce
those ideas because they too have
experienced that that's good business
and when we tried to go outside and
bring in people it immediately became
apparent that finding someone who wasn't
part of the growth story of Adobe never
quite understood why that
particular culture was so important so
the man who replaced John and myself was
a fellow from the inside Bruce Chisholm
who have run our sort of consumer
products area the next replacement under
Shantanu Narayan has been with Adobe for
about 15 years I guess by now and he's
also of course from inside and he's
doing an incredible job and we've been
very fortunate the other lesson you
learn is you look at what happens at
other companies and even a great company
like youlet Packard has gone through
some very difficult times in terms of
maintaining at its position and its
culture and we're going to fight it as
long as we're around and hopefully
people will see the value and I can
continue to do that after we're no
longer involved
aggravated the market and some like it
was to all in the market here was what
it was too early in the market because
the market was not ready
well again you don't want to be second
that's the critical point I was trying
to make and the second thing is you have
to be prepared to fight for that number
one position not just outside but inside
so when we introduce Photoshop all the
people who are making all the profit and
all the money and PostScript said why
the hell are we wasting our time with
that thing it's just a toy remember a
Macintosh in those days had a little
black and white screen and if you were a
power user you had 20 megabytes I
wouldn't hold many photographs but again
the leaders had happen to be John and me
at that time said no our instincts say
this is going to happen and so after
about two years all of a sudden boom it
took off but you you have to have that
conviction and you have to stick with it
we've been lucky because we made some
very good calls we also had a few
products we introduced that we don't
talk about anymore because they don't
exist but they we didn't put a lot of
money behind them and fortunately we
found out early that they weren't going
to have that property it was the same
problem by the way with Acrobat but then
it was the Photoshop people were saying
why are you spending this money on
Acrobat Photoshop is the number one
selling graphics application in the
world why would you waste your time and
again John and I instinctively knew that
it was cheaper to send digital paper and
printed if you wanted to print it at the
point of consumption was easier to store
it it was easier to retrieve it if it
stayed digital and that's why the way I
always have thought about Acrobat is
it's digital paper and that has turned
out to be incredibly valuable asset to
the
but again we had to make sure the
antibodies didn't kill it because of my
story about the ARPA thing I don't think
it would be as much as you think if it
were done that way what really has to
happen in the United States is we need
to increase revenue there are two ways
to increase revenue one is to get the
economy to super heat build a lot of
taxable by current tax law revenue or to
raise taxes I don't believe that just
cutting is going to work when I look at
a business and I think about investing
in if they're making their profits by
cutting their costs that's a bad
investment a good investment is a
company who figures out how to leverage
its investments in a way that will in
the long term grow the business and keep
investing in it so I think the biggest
challenge is not the money it's the will
and everybody who runs for political
office says they want to improve
education until they get the office then
they don't do a damn thing
excuse me
my oldest son is a school teacher so I
very sensitive to this topic you know
unless we're prepared to do that things
are gonna continue in this direction all
the bright kids except for the ones in
this room go off to Wall Street because
it's the quick buck that doesn't make
anything that's productive
startup companies oh absolutely yes not
a problem in fact to a certain extent
good investors are looking for those
opportunities because to the extent
there's and there always is competition
for talent that competition within the
geographic region of Silicon Valley is
very intense and in fact if we are as a
region are not careful all we do is move
employees in a circle through all of the
companies there that's not a very
productive thing to do so no I don't
think that's the issue the issue is
having a great idea because of the
internet and high bandwidth you can be
anywhere in the world if Antarctica
where it's a great place to recruit
scientists go to Antarctica doesn't
matter so what that isn't the issue I
mean you do need to have an
infrastructure of law firms and you know
things like that and venture people who
are prepared to get on a plane and get
out of solar oh well I know I don't have
any venture great I thank you so much it
was great to be